[Musique]
on
wanna
die tu nous as tous et toutes
neji dhaou
nous avons
ici
[Musique]
depuis 50 ans les habitants de christina
rose se bat
contre le mercure qui polluent leurs
lacs et leurs rivières
contre ses effets toxiques sur leur
santé et contre les gouvernements qui
tarde à reconnaître les préjudices subis
par la communauté
[Musique]
bakou
la communauté autochtone située dans le
nord ouest de l'ontario compte
maintenant une alliée la scientifique
dans nos moeurs craint
ce que le canada a fait au peuple
autochtone est épouvantable y'a pas de
mots pour décrire nous sommes des
colonisateurs
épouvantable
ma petite contribution
et de leur offrir la science qui ce que
je sais est de pouvoir documenter
en termes scientifiques ce qui s'est
passé ce qui se passe à l'heure actuelle
dans ce cas de cette communauté
christina rose est une communauté
anishinabe de 1200 habitants située près
de la frontière du manitoba
[Musique]
autrefois des pêcheurs américains
venaient jusqu'ici pour taquiner le
poisson dans ce formidable dédale de
lacs et de rivières
c'était avant que ne survienne l'une des
pire catastrophe environnementale de
l'histoire du canada
de 1962 à 1975 10 tonnes de mercure ont
été déversés dans les rivières web
higuain et english par une usine de pâte
et papier située à dryden en ontario
le polluant s'est propagé sur plus de
100 kilomètres en aval
les communautés autochtones de kratie
n'arrose et white dogues ont perdu leur
santé leur gagne-pain et leurs
traditions
4 claude camors aux pessimistes claude
garaud mindana tenait
mais une autre crise aura pas s'agace
eastwood star édition doit faire
surseoir à ce stade
des fraises et les
gros canons
dehors le pipeau
john rich un
clip au food for pi pas son nom
le mercure est un métal lourd dans les
lacs et les rivières il se dépose tout
au fond dans les sédiments
au contact de certaines bactéries ils se
changent dans sa forme la plus toxique
le méthylmercure
le méthylmercure est absorbée par les
insectes par les verts et éventuellement
par les poissons qui les consomment
il s'accumule dans la chair des poissons
qui se trouve au sommet de la chaîne
alimentaire
lusine de dryden a cessé de déverser du
mercure dans les rivières baby gone et
une riche en 1975 la concentration de
méthyle mercure dans les poissons à
baisser progressivement jusqu'en 1985
mais depuis elle stagne
car encore aujourd'hui du mercure se
trouve dans les sédiments au fond des
lacs et des rivières
[Musique]
pour réduire leur exposition mercure des
habitants de grassy narrows et de wild
hog ont beaucoup diminué leur
consommation de poisson mais les jours
de fête le doré jaune est encore au menu
un poisson très prisé mais
particulièrement contaminée
ou historiques
djoudi da silva milite depuis des
décennies pour documenter les impacts du
mercure sur sa communauté et obtenir
justice
pour
[Musique]
le neurophysiologiste donna mergler est
professeur émérite à l'université du
québec à montréal
elle a passé sa carrière étudier
l'impact des polluants sur la santé
humaine
à l'âge de 77 ans et les plus actifs que
jamais
des raisons pour lesquelles je fais
l'effort de travailler avec les gens de
grassy narrows et parce que ce sont des
batailleurs
dans la même classe a travaillé en
amazonie là-bas et la documenter
l'impact du mercure sur les communautés
vivant en bordure de la rivière tapas
ross au brésil
mais c'est surtout la tragédie de
minamata au japon qui a mis en lumière
les effets dévastateurs du mercure sur
la santé humaine
entre 1932 et 1966 une usine de produits
chimiques à rejeter des quantités
massives de mercure dans la baie de
minamata
on a un prix que j'étais maladies
neurologiques
c'est une maladie qui implique des
changements au niveau de la codp nature
motrice des tremblements
la perte de vision surtout à grassy
narrows on observe des symptômes
similaires
en prenant
1,14 de moi sauf par leurs
homologues
to grab son plein comme un oeuf urbain
certains habitants de grassy narrows nés
après 1962 ont été contaminées avant
même de naître
ne meure no cure est active en
transporter à travers le placenta donc à
la naissance quand on mesure là le
mercure dans le cordon ombilical
le mercure dans le cordon ombilical est
presque deux fois plus élevé que la met
au coeur dans le champ de la mer
entre 1970 et 1997 le gouvernement
fédéral a mené un programme de
surveillance accrue à cinar aux hawaï
dog et dans d'autres communautés
autochtones à travers le pays
on a prélevé des échantillons de sang le
cheveu et de cordons ombilicaux pour
mesurer l'exposition des autochtones au
mercure
racinaire aux 760 personnes participer à
ce programme de surveillance
pendant des années le gouvernement a
refusé de partager la base de données
avec les communautés concernées
et après des années des années d'efforts
et de volonté la communauté a réussi à
récupérer en 2019
aline philibert et épidémiologiste et
proche collaboratrice de dans la main
craint elle a passé des mois à
décortiquer les chiffres on a pu prouver
d'une manière mathématique
quantitatives que tout ce qu'ils ont
racontées depuis cinquante d'années et
ben est vrai c'est c'est des preuves
irréfutables
la chercheuse a démontré qu'à krassine
arrose l'exposition au mercure réduit
significativement l'espérance de vie un
tiers des gens qui avaient 20 ans 1970
n'ont pas pu passer le stade des 60 ans
si on sépare par genre chez les femmes
c'est un quart et chez les hommes c'est
45 %
à l'une philibert a calculé que la
longévité des habitants de grassy
narrows diminué d'un an pour chaque
augmentation
6,5 microgrammes de mercure par gramme
de cheveux les résultats ont fait le
tour du monde
en 1985 les communautés de grassy
narrows aywaille dogues ont conclu une
entente avec les gouvernements du canada
de l'ontario et deux sociétés qui ont
opéré les usines de pâtes et papiers à
dryden
cette entente a mené à la création du
mcri des super outil board chargé de
verser des indemnisations aux victimes
pour se qualifier les membres des
communautés doivent se soumettre à un
examen neurologique
on donne à houston aysat cobaric twitter
n'a fallu des salles aucune colle un
ghost nos monstres non
seulement 14% des habitants de kratie
n'arrose ont reçu une compensation à ce
jour
les plus malades reçoivent 1800 dollars
par mois
y a pas juste un effet du mercure sur la
santé il ya un effet du mercure sur
l'ensemble du fonctionnement d'une
société pour préserver leur identité les
survivants de christina rose continue de
se battre
2-1 à 9,02 dollars
juillet 2021 l'école de grassy narrows
une communauté anishinabe de 1200
habitants et transformé en laboratoire
des membres de la communauté se
soumettent à une batterie de tests dans
le cadre d'un projet de recherche
pour la première fois depuis le
déversement de 10 tonnes de mercure dans
leurs lacs et les rivières on va mesurer
de façon approfondie l'impact du
polluant sur leur santé la
neurophysiologie st-john amoureux a
réuni des médecins des autos mais triste
des infirmières et des chercheurs du
québec et de l'ontario c'est quelque
chose qui aurait dû être fait il y à 50
ans il ya 40 ans il ya trente ans il ya
vingt ans il ya dix ans
et malheureusement c'est que aujourd'hui
qu'on le fait
dans une salle de classe aménagée en
clinique d'optométrie annie châtillon
examine la rétine des participants le
méthylmercure a tendance à s'y accumuler
l'une des premières répercussions c'est
la perte de vision périphérique
societas est évident qu'un impact porte
l'âge des patients qu'on voit donc à des
patients dans la quarantaine
cinquantaine qui ont les champs d'usan
qui sont très restreints qui est quelque
chose qu'on voit pas avec des examens à
l'extérieur d'ici ou en ville de l'autre
côté du couloir d assistante de
recherche évalue les performances à des
tests sensoriels et moteurs
[Musique]
en perturbant le système nerveux le
mercure compromet la dextérité manuelle
la coordination des mouvements et la
sensibilité tactile
les effets du mercure sur la santé sont
progressifs les symptômes sont
généralement plus handicapant chez les
personnes âgées
[Musique]
les chercheurs espèrent faire le lien
entre l'exposition au mercure et les
symptômes même les plus utiles
ailleurs dans l'école les participants
se soumettent à des prises de sang à des
examens neurologiques et psychologiques
ainsi qu'un bilan de santé général
mais je m'assure que les symptômes ne
sont pas causés par autre chose que le
mercure
par exemple si un patient souffre de
neuropathie au pied beaucoup de médecins
conclurait que c'est du diabète mais en
faisant un examen approfondi si on se
rend compte que le patient ne souffre
pas d diabète sévère ok alors il ya
forcément une autre explication comme le
mercure est maculée
aux historiens et médecins de famille
mohacs originaire de kahnawake
pour elle les médecins sont souvent trop
rapide a blâmé l'alcool la mauvaise
alimentation ou la sédentarité pour
expliquer les problèmes de santé des
autochtones
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup plus facile de blâmer un
individu que de réaliser que c'est son
environnement qui le rend malade
l'un des principaux objectifs du projet
de ton hammer c'est d'aboutir à une
réelle prise en charge des malades qui
souffrent d'empoisonnement au mercure
[Musique]
on ne veut pas terminer la recherche et
sont allés on veut s'assurer que nos
données servent à élaborer les soins qui
sont offerts aux patients
[Musique]
après des décennies de lutte pour
obtenir justice
la communauté de grassy narrows
entrevoit des signes encourageants dans
l'horreur a récemment présidé un panel
d'experts pour réformer leurs cris des
abrutis brouille au mois de février 2021
ce comité a déposé cinquante et une
recommandation ou veut instaurer un
processus d'évaluation et de
compensation pour les victimes qui
soient plus respectueux plus juste et
qui tiennent compte des connaissances
actuelles sur le mercure est selon moi
des médecins qui viennent pratiquer dans
la région ici devrait avoir une
formation obligatoire sur les effets du
mercure au mois de juin dernier la
communauté a gagné une autre bataille
elle a obtenu le financement du
gouvernement fédéral pour mettre sur
pied un centre de soins spécialisés à
christina hu
doit ouvrir ses portes en 2023
on connaît tous des gens qui ont eu des
accidents ou des arrivées qui reprennent
mais ils reprennent avec un équipe qui
travaille avec eux mais cette
récupération ne se fait pas ici les gens
le font les hommes aiment aussi bien
qu'ils peuvent et c'est ça que le chante
d'affaires pour les patients qui
souffrent des symptômes les plus
handicapants le nouveau centre offrira
des soins de longue durée
les malades n'auront plus à quitter car
si nadal
[Musique]
n 1 a donné libre cours à leurs familles
nos
amis nos
d'autres victoire se profile à l'horizon
l'été dernier des autochtones
travaillait sur le terrain avec les
techniciens d'une société d'experts
conseils en environnement
les équipes prélever des échantillons
d'eau de poissons sédiments de dryden
jusqu'à green house on tente
d'identifier les endroits il plus
contaminés par le mercure
le gouvernement de l'ontario a octroyé
85 millions de dollars pour tenter de
décontaminer les sédiments
de
queen à
[Musique]
la réforme du meeting
la mise sur pied d'un centre de soins
spécialisé
le projet de décontamination des lacs et
des rivières
pour les militantes comme crucial ex ce
sont de petites victoires
tant que ce rêve ne sera pas devenu
réalité dans la main tu ne comptes pas
baisser la garde notre apport pour cette
communauté n'a pas eu la passion que
nous que moi je peux aider cette
communauté c'est de faire la meilleure
science possible de s'assurer que nos
données sont prises de façon rigoureuse
que nos conclusions sur vigoureuse et
sont connues de tout le monde